good morning it was too early for this
[ __ ] so let's go see
what my mom's doing i want to give them
a daily vlog
and what i usually do is i wake up and i
annoy my mother could you make me
breakfast
uh no i won't i'm not taking your dad to
the doctor
really you're going to put them above me
yes i am so selfish
i just want to give them like a like a
inside scoop and what i do in a day
got it i usually wake up and i go find
you
yeah and then i usually she's being
dramatic it's the highlight of her day
it's the highlight every day get out of
here and i usually go
and i pet my dog look at this
hello honey i brought you a bagel hi
honey it's the best thing that ever
happened to you
and i love you so much i love you more
there you go anyways annoyed my second
person of the day
okay so usually the third thing i do is
annoy eva hi honey
nobody loves you and you're useless to
this household that's not true
you could say that but you know that's
not true hi honey good morning
she really just doesn't know how to
express her love to me but she does love
me
don't worry so you're gonna tell me
i don't love you you're useless in this
household
well you're useless unless you're making
food i'm like no i'm not gonna make you
damn case i would have he didn't
greet me like that it's like the
audacity i made you a quesadilla the
other day too
acting like i'm useless i'm the one
getting i'm getting our family reality
tv show going so we never have to work
again
we'll be the ginger kardashians see it's
like nobody appreciates me here
today i'm going to florida so there's
gonna be
it'll be a fun trip it'll be a fun trip
she'll miss me when i'm gone do you
think i should move to la yet
wait really i thought you were just
saying
you think i'm big enough do you think i
should be an la tick tocker
oh i'm not saying because you're big
enough i'm just saying because then
there'd be more space in this house
yeah we have plenty of space this house
is huge
not big enough what do you get anyways
so this is what i deal with on a daily
basis it's okay luckily for me my
self-esteem is very high
so i don't need no validation
i don't need no validation yeah yeah
okay you don't need no validation
except from tick tock but i love you
you're beautiful
adam i'm taking them through a daily
vlog with me and i just said i go
through all my siblings to see if i can
annoy them hi adam
get out it's a bb gun guys don't
i mean i still don't think you should
point that at my head it was a little
more
adam's going on the trip to florida
today all right guys
we are going to florida and just getting
excited my cousin jess
is coming this is her keeper humble um
[Laughter]
we keep everyone humbly
okay guys so we're in the we're in the
back of the house
here i'm bringing josh with me
we want their church to this place it's
pretty cool
this is crazy so like
this is the back of the house
yeah it's happening right there
okay guys so the other thing i do when
i'm here
is i got this piano and i literally just
spent
hours literally hours just like playing
the piano
i'll show you guys the kitchen i don't
know what they're doing here yeah
it's it's homemade whipped cream with
the heavy base you know why are you
talking
that's dookie staying green
[Laughter]
we got miguel out here he's um chefing
it up
he stole my man he stole my name and how
does it happen no i bet stole your man
you
how could you do that i thought i
thought we had something special
i thought we didn't that's what it does
that speaks to my heart it's like
oh my goodness and here i thought we
were in love you gotta give me a steak
or something
if i could if i cooked you steak could i
win you back yeah
some steak some fried chicken
you want some ribs with some mac and
cheese i got you that mac and cheese
don't love using it like this steak
guys so these are the women we already
went through the guys of the trip but
these are the girls of the trip
yeah we got some cooking going on don't
look at the burnt pan i'm so sorry i
am i really am a better cook than this i
was gonna say i was getting i was gonna
say wife material
this is my cousin jess hello i think we
met her on the way
there and now we're going to go bother
my brother
say hi good morning i'm about to go for
a run
over and that's pretty much everyone on
the trip
we're about to play hide and go seek do
you feel like do you feel confident in
your abilities to find people
i feel 100 confident 100 what do you
guys think i have
i have an advantage i'm five five i'm
very short i can fit places
how do you feel how do you feel about
the women they can't catch me
don't start on that one okay she's the
first one to go
okay ready let's go let's go king let's
go
i'm gonna hide here i don't know if
they'll find me or not i think
this is a pretty good hiding spot i
guess
wait yo me was i last did i win
all right i'm deemed the winner of this
round
cheaters never win i feel like i did
amazing you know i'm saying i
found everybody from josh even though he
cheated
good job on me who's who's the winner
the real winner
[Applause]
all right guys i was supposed to i can't
even believe
this what just happened to me i was
supposed to marry josh this weekend
we were going to be the world's most
mismatched couple
in terms of live tell them what happened
and then he just left me
he left me
this guy looks this guy this guy looks
like sparkle
i was gonna say chocolate oh wow
we're not
yeah so now i'm just you know left by
myself
okay this is my dude um i decided i was
single for too long so i made myself a
boyfriend
in the sand
close your eyes i really like the new
look man
this is what it's like when you go to
florida with the church
always always someone playing this piano
look at that we're going to this like
garden type thing it's kind of
overcast i'm going to show you it's like
kind of rainy out
not super nice so we're going to be
doing
some stuff like at this garden
type thing i don't even know today i
didn't film as much
but we really just went to this like
garden it was kind of lame
honestly um we got lunch that was so
good
caroline's been the mom of this trip
because i don't have any motherly
instinct
wow which is sad because i don't really
either so
she's been out here planning stuff
directing the group
i i do feel like a big mama bear when
i'm driving the escalade around
with like all the like people in the
back a real queen
a real queen
i actually i can't like guarantee that i
would oh okay
[Music]
we're back out here back out here
look at this
say hi all right there's only a couple
sharks in the water
it's okay only a couple they won't hurt
you bruce is my friend though right
see everyone's just like this thing
but yeah okay guys don't be fooled
don't be fooled the boys are not as nice
as they seem
they will shove you in 500.
what do you do what do you have to say
for yourself well
it was all the big homies out there and
you know had to show what i did you know
don't be fooled don't be fooled they may
seem nice
but when but when the football comes out
the gloves
they come off okay who would we say was
most improved
today most improved for well i got to
throw the ball
maybe josh maybe josh i'll give it to
you
but best player obviously
what okay this is like i'm gonna award
myself
best player i'm gonna award myself mvp
because these boys don't know what
they're talking about
okay guys it was a fun trip this is the
end of the road
in florida goodbye
house
how did you feel about this trip was
awesome
thank you we made it on the plane tsa
was a little scary
but not if you're a davis
we kill it we kill it out here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you